σττα θεωρο εταξέ το ξέρεις φυσικά ότι αρά που γνώριζε τα τα λάθη που γίνονταν
οι πρώτες μέρες λογικά εβάλε στόχο τα αλλάθει να γίνουν σοστανομίζε ότι όταν έμαθα ότι
υπάω στις σύταστες τριάντα ο εμβρίους τη γιορτή μου του δύο ιλας δεκα οκτώ και
ξεκινούσα αρχές ι αννοαρίου του δεκαι πότε είχα περίπου ενάμησι μείνα τον οποίο νάμεηση μείνα
εξεκινησα να σχεδιάζω τη πρώτη μέρα είτες πρώτες μέρες μιλούσαμε κόσμο όλους που ήξερα στις
ήταν να προσπαθήήσω να να κάσουν να σχεδιάσω και ς πρώοι πρώτες μέρες ήταν πλήρος
προετημασμένες από πριν και αυτόμε βοήθησε παραπολύ εκαν αυτό που λένε οι άγκλιχιτκράον ράνι δηλαδή
από την πρώτη μέρα ήμουν παραγωγικός και μαζί με την νομάδα που ήταν εκεί ξεκινήσαμε
μια μπορεία αλλαγής για τη ίτα οι οποίαακόμας συνεχίζεα κι στοχι του μίλου του οργανισμόύ
αλλά και ιδιοκή σας προσωπικά για τα επόμενα χρόνια για τη σύα κιτης τα αυτή
τη στιγμή αντικιμενικά δικάποιος θα κρίε και θα πει ότι είναι μια εταιρεία επιτυχημένοι και
σε οικονομικού στομής αλλά και σε άλλους δείκτες αυτό που είαι ο στόχος είναι ι
αυτή επιτυχία να μην είναι προσωριν α πρέπει να διασφαλίσουμε όλοι που είμαστε σε υπεύθυνες
θέσι στις στ ότι δημιουργούμε κουρτούραν επιτυχίας στον οργανισμό και όχι μια ευκαιριακή βελτιώσι των
αριθμό οι οποία μετά όταν αλλάξουν τα άτομα θα χαθείν και αυτό είναι το υπρόκληση
που έχουμε όλι δεν είναι καθόλου εύκολο από υτό αλλά αυτό είναι αμερωτς